this is a Sky News special program live
from Pakistan a country desperately
grappling with some of the worst
flooding in its history
the scale of the devastation is
unimaginable with more than a thousand
people dead and millions more left with
nothing
Aid agencies say help is beginning to
arrive but it's nowhere near enough to
prevent a human catastrophe
I think people were very shell-shocked
at the beginning but now actually they
seem to be getting angry about the lack
of Aid that's getting to them
[Music]
in this special program we report from
across Pakistan as it braces for even
more rain and yet more disastrous flash
flooding
now it's so late and in some cases it's
20 feet deep
in the UK an outpouring of support for
the people of Pakistan and a
determination to help some of them don't
have food and they're suffering and a
lot of people have so I think we should
help them and it will be very kind too
[Music]
good afternoon from Pakistan a country
devastated by flooding in this special
Sky News program we'll report from right
across Pakistan as millions of people
try to survive in the face of a
desperate unfolding tragedy a third of
this country is now underwater a week
after Monsoon rain Swept Away lives land
and livelihoods
all four provinces are have been
affected tens of millions have lost
their homes and thousands of buildings
roads and bridges destroyed
in the South some areas of Balochistan
and Sindh saw a 400 increase in average
rainfall this monsoon season
and more flood waters are coming as the
Indus River which runs from the
Himalayas down to the Arabian Sea is
overflowing
people here in the district of dardu are
now being urged to move to Higher Ground
to avoid the surge but for many there's
no help to get them to safety
I'm in seven Sharif in southern Pakistan
and will report on The Exodus of whole
communities as they try to flee the
flood waters
Sky's Cordelia Lynch will report from
nearby Dadu where people say there's not
enough help to get them to safety
but our first report comes from our
chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey he's
been to the town of Bahrain in the
mountain of SWAT Valley in
homemade is getting through them this is
desperation Beyond a no doubt about it
the disaster caused by this catastrophic
event is far from over there's very
little Aid relief getting through when
it does chaos can be moments away
the relief truck is overwhelmed
they scramble on board grabbing what
they can find
many have lost everything and families
will have anything
the streets of towns along the swap
River are filled with people growing
increasingly desperate
the Army and police are here to keep
order but imposing that order will get
harder as the days pass it's been a real
change in atmosphere here in the last
few days
I think people were very shell-shocked
at the beginning but now actually they
should be getting angry about the lack
of Aid that's getting to them of course
many of the villages that they're coming
from completely cut off so it's it's
really desperate the VT goes by they're
getting more and more angry
Bahrain is a major town it's been split
in half by the flood but there is food
here Beyond there are more than 200 000
people who remain cut off in the
mountains
Through The Battered Town thousands make
their way with whatever they can carry
strapped to their backs
it starts at this rickety Bridge
streaming across for the start of a
dangerous Trek to find their families
they fought six to nine hours to get
here and they will walk back again
they are all exhausted already but they
have no choice but to make the journey
Khalid with lentils flour and oil is on
his way back to his wife children mother
and father they're all waiting for him
he says it's a tough climb to get there
but he has simply no choice
foreign
people it's as simple as that and they
know this
the point is these people have simply
given up waiting they've come long
distances and now that they've got
whatever Provisions they could get
they're going to head back home it's
about 35 kilometers away incredibly over
those mountains
the flood has now severed the only Road
out of Bahrain the river shifted its
position
the locals crisscross the torrent on
rickety Bridges and even more perilous
cable trolleys
we met sham Shire in the remains of her
home she is 105 years old
like so many here she believes the
changing weather
has caused all this
is
the centenarian husband Cherry Gull
agrees with his wife
[Music]
amid the destruction families adapt to
the new shape of their Town washing in
the midst of the newly arrived boulders
but the real priority here is to
redirect the river and to start building
bridges and repairing roads heading
north everything Beyond this point is
destroyed
people are scattered from that side
because no link
Bridges or all languages are washed away
by the flood but alhamdulillah they said
local people are help each other a
little bit but the relief is not enough
for us we need a lot of a lot of
foods items and medicines and such more
items for home shelters
Etc that that will be a little bit good
for us
neither Faith or resolve can be doubted
in Pakistan
but this is simply overwhelming and they
desperately need help
Stuart Ramsey Sky News Bahrain in the
swamp Valley
well Stuart has actually moved now to
the city of
Bali from where he joins me now and
Stuart as your report clearly shows uh
getting AIDS in difficult hard to reach
areas is is proving pretty tough for
people there it's a problem that's
certainly not going to go away is it
it really isn't going away and you're
absolutely right you know it's getting
the aid is one thing honest there's not
enough coming into the country already
and it's not being distributed properly
to the people who are actually
um need it we're seeing ad hot
deliveries but simply and not enough and
I think one of the other issues of
course as you pointed out is the
infrastructure
um you know whole uh towns Villages
Bridges roads have been destroyed I say
we drove up the SWAT Valley it is
actually remarkable
um seeing nature uh destroy things in
such a huge scale and put it in
perspective the town that we were
filming in you can't reach anymore the
roads that we drove over have slipped
they're now impassable and the
authorities are trying to to get those
sorted out at the moment about 200 000
people are being supplied by helicopters
that's simply not enough Pakistan Army
just can't deal with the sort of volume
of people who need a lot of help and of
course you've always got to remember the
railing season hasn't ended yet
um it's perhaps in the next 14 days
we're told that it could start pouring
with rain now even if it's not
particularly heavy in these communities
that have already been hit by a huge
amount of water more coming down is
going to make things even worse so it
really is a big big problem and it isn't
going away like a lot of natural
disasters things actually get worse as
as time goes on not better
yeah and Stuart you and I have been down
that uh one road towards the SWAT Valley
many times it is a treacherous Journey
as it is are people I know people aren't
able to get in so much to get to them
but what about people trying to get out
as well how is that faring and where are
they going to
no okay so what what's happening we've
noticed because you saw in that report
that people are actually coming out of
these cut off towns and Villages and
trying to come and get food it's very
interesting but when you get to Bahrain
that's like the gateway to the rest of
the valley so there's plenty of supplies
coming to there but they can't get them
further on because really there is just
no way that the bridge in that town has
gone and virtually all the bridges and
Roads Beyond it have gone so people are
walking over the the mountains the
thought of a mass movement of people
down taking this nine six to nine hour
walk over the mountains
um it's one thing for young men but for
whole families I'd say it's virtually
impossible what we understand you're
gonna remember firstly that it's only
houses and and businesses I say only but
it's it's the houses and businesses
right next to the river that are
destroyed most of the other towns and
Villages of course by the river anything
from behind there their houses are still
intact so there's no real reason uh for
them to leave other than lack of
resources and so as soon as that could
get sorted a bigger Aid list maybe that
would help crucially it's trying to
build build those roads now local
government officials have said they
could do that in the next five days I'll
be honest with you I just don't think
that's
physically possible not least because
one of the roads that we were on as I
was saying has already collapsed even
though there was traffic moving along it
for the past few days so it just shows
that even an area that has actually been
made safe if you like can fall well
those areas Beyond it they haven't even
started work on them and also in Bahrain
the main bridge that they need to get
built across so that they can get
further north is nowhere near being
completed they're still trying to divert
the river that has come the wrong way so
that they can then start building the
bridge it really is a huge huge
Monumental task what it's like for those
people we don't know because we just
haven't been able to get there yet but
one has to assume that
I suppose mainly the men folk will just
have to keep doing these incredible
Journeys to try and get food to them as
best they can but we know that the
communities there are working really
well together so that they will look
after one another but it's really
desperate no doubt about it
yeah I think I have to say same as what
I'm seeing here in the south of Pakistan
there is ambitious projections of being
able to fix roads and bridges uh
sharpish but when they're struggling
with the rescue effort alone rebuilding
seems a pretty long way off doesn't it
let's talk about that rescue efforts to
it because as you mentioned in your
report they're using a lot of
helicopters to get to heart to reach
areas and of course trying to do Aid
drops as well but we know that the
weather is set to get worse not just the
monsoon rains but of course also as
autumn and winter sets in in the higher
regions in Pakistan that often means
that you simply can't fly in that
weather and so in the months to come if
we look ahead things are going to get
worse
yeah and that's been happening actually
uh over the last few days
um I I know that the Prime Minister for
example wanted to go to a number of
areas he's been doing a tour of the
country and a number of occasions uh I'm
told he wasn't able to fly because the
weather conditions were too dangerous
and you're absolutely right we know
we're seeing when we were out yesterday
I think we were seeing three or four
helicopters passing over us I don't
think I didn't count anymore we're told
it's up to 15 maybe 20. uh helicopters
are going you're absolutely right if the
weather closes in again they just simply
can't fly but I suppose crucially much
more to the point you know you'll get a
helicopter that is doing this type of
relief Mission and it can be absolutely
full of of goods that are needed by the
people but actually it really is a drop
in the ocean for 200 000 people
um the distribution there are no real
distribution centers up there we know
that even on the the road distribution
centers they can descend into chaos very
quickly so distribution in remote
communities and even large towns in
helicopters is inherently dangerous in
its own right because people who are
very desperate have a tendency to Surge
forward to try and get
what's being delivered and that can be
incredibly dangerous I've seen it in so
many natural disasters over the years
where it that turns into a disaster in
itself trying to deliver the uh the
supplies to the people I think what we
really need to see is a sort of really
well organized Distribution Center up
the valley
um into the areas that really need it
but that that is hard to do Pakistan is
crying out for help it says it really
doesn't have the resources to do it we
know the economy is in a real mess it
also it means sort of needs a massive uh
airlift by sort of a United Nations type
um movement to try and contain the
problem in an area and to get food in on
a sort of continuous daily daily basis
you're absolutely right if this weather
front closes in on I'm told it could
even start today then it's going to be
really miserable up the valley
Stuart Ramsey live from mingora in the
swap Valley thanks very much indeed
well our chief correspondent was giving
you a perspective there from the north
of the country let's bring you to the
South now and more rain is forecast in
the dardu district that's just a couple
of hours up the Indus highway from where
I am right now and people there are
being urged to move to Higher Ground our
Sky correspondent Cordelia Lynch reports
now from a marooned Village
you can easily lose sight of the loss
here of the lives buried beneath the
crops the homes the hope
we're in the catcher area of Dadu in
Sindh province
a window into a community that's
drowning in change
this is normally
completely dry and look at it now it's
so late and in some places it's 20 feet
deep and there are whole Villages
completely submerged
[Music]
stranded standing on what little land is
left these are the people of Jan
Muhammad
huddled together
here for three weeks with no access to
Aid clinging onto each other
now cartoon tells me no one came here to
help thank goodness I got my children
here but they have fevers and stomach
problems
she wants to show me where her home once
stood
this is your house
completely underwater ah
okay
this has become an island and they are
among the most vulnerable there's about
a hundred people living here lots of
them children many of them sick they are
desperate to leave but they're worried
there's just no shelter and no food for
them anywhere else
[Music]
it's cramped space and sanitation in
short supply
and so is medicine with disease
spreading
this boy has spots all over his body his
mother believes it's caused by the flood
water
they're exhausted but the water is
rising and it's a risk staying put many
of the children in this area are already
malnourished
there could be very hard days ahead
the only one
while they fight for survival their
education is on hold this is the local
school and they've lost their places of
prayer too
where they walk was once a road and they
can't see a way out
this is being called a climate Hot Spot
the victim of a world that's playing
catch-up
and Cordelia has now moved to the town
of juhi still in the district of Derby
which has also been affected and she
sends this latest report
Pakistan is stepping up its Aid effort
and more food and water are reaching
hard-hit communities the water in the
north is also thankfully receding but
here in the south in the Sin Province
where I am the situation is still very
live this is safwan Sharif and here is
the focus of the concern look at the
water here 22 feet deep that is
remarkable because this is normally dry
and Beyond those tree those trees there
is a place called manchar Lake now water
is coming there from the north from
Balochistan they're also expecting more
rain in the next few days now if that
water comes here and Rises just a few
feet breaching this wall
it will run into the neighboring
communities they're trying desperately
to prevent that they are keeping
constant watch of this area they're
laying sandbags they're using different
techniques to try and prevent it from
happening but it's still a deep concern
well I'm in servant Sharif for just
further down the road along the Indus
Highway and in fact over the last week
since me and my team have been here
we've been traveling along the Indus
Highway the main Highway in the Sin
District to try and gauge the movement
of the water and one night in the middle
of the week we heard that yet more towns
had been besieged by water as we drove
out along the Indus highway to to find
where this water was coming from we
suddenly came to uh Halton a complete
standstill the main Highway was flooded
with People Cattle chickens tents and
suddenly had become a tented City in
fact the the lines from the highway you
could see were going right down into the
water as a couple of flood barriers now
Pakistan this part of the world doesn't
have many but those flood barriers had
breached overnight flooding a huge
expand months of land I have to say it
is extraordinary sometimes we look out
and it feels like you're looking at a
sea not somewhere there once used to be
land and houses we actually joined the
army which are carrying out a rescue
effort so far they've managed to save 50
000 people
but as we've been saying all week more
than 30 million people have been
affected so that is just scratching the
surface but here's a story of one family
being rescued on an army boat
there's been more flooding the water has
breached yet another flood defense and
this Invader is taking over
this is the Indus highway it's a road
to Nowhere it's completely submerged in
water now and the only way you can get
anywhere is by boat we're about to join
a rescue mission because of the people
that are trapped far out there
Segundo is desperate his family is stuck
in their home the water suddenly burst
in
foreign
[Music]
we have gone through Village after
Village and every single house is
completely submerged not just the ground
floors but the first and second floors
in the bigger houses this is incredibly
deep water don't know
[Music]
after an hour and a half we finally
reached segunda's home and the rescue
mission is well underway
the children and women are scared
but here too not everyone wants to leave
the family home
tearful departure
come on
it takes more than three hours to carry
out this rescue it's traumatic and
emotional
foreign
[Music]
and finally on dry ground yet their
ordeal is not over it's only just begun
they have nowhere to sleep nothing to
eat and have lost their livelihoods in
the farms nearby it's all underwater
foreign
let's turn our attention now to the
global effort to help the people of
Pakistan the United Nations has appealed
for
136 million pounds to help fund relief
operations here and the UK has pledged
to provide 15 million pounds of that Aid
effort
people across the United Kingdom are
doing their bit to try to help too Skies
Saba Chaudhry reports now from
Peterborough
foreign
this call to prayer is a call to action
to Muslims faith is a verb more than
just reading it's putting principles
into practice
he tests different people on different
days tomorrow it could be us that is
going through a flood famine droughts
hunger difficulty we don't want that to
be us and should that be us we are going
to find rest in the fact that there are
our brothers and sisters across the
globe who are going to help us offering
in Pakistan Brothers the floods may have
happened four thousand miles away in
Pakistan but the scale of suffering is
felt strongly among Britain's Muslims
charity is a pillar of the faith
if you're planting good seeds and
hopefully you'll be able to to sow some
good commas in in the future some of
them don't have food and they're
suffering and a lot of people have so I
think we should help them and it will be
very kind too parents are suffering as
well because what their children need to
feed us
despite the cost of living up to 6 000
pounds was raised in one hour
small change to many making a big
difference
the fundraise from today's collection is
going to go on to help provide emergency
aids to those that are vulnerable at the
moment from Food Packs to emergency
hygiene kits to even uh putting people
into a shelter as well
[Music]
back at the congregation empty your
wallets but prayers heavy with hope for
the people of Pakistan Saba chowdry Sky
News Finsbury Park
King efforts to try and help people here
in Pakistan and sky
wired joins me live now from
Peterborough I should tell us about the
efforts people are making there to try
to help
well up and down the country local
groups communities Charities are coming
together to raise money and that's
exactly what they're doing here at
children of Adams they've held various
fundraising events throughout the week
and they say they've raised around 30
000 pounds so far we can speak to one of
the co-founders shuja so you've been on
a bike ride today tell me about that but
also tell me about the other events
you've held over the last few weeks um
well it's basically this week since the
floods have got worse we've had a radio
appeal where we raised over 22 000
pounds we ride a cake bake sale which
raised roughly about four thousand
pounds and some of the lads went on a
bike ride today was raised about how
much was that about 2 000 pounds today
so and we're going to keep raising and
keep going until basically we can get
enough assistance out there that's
needed
and how much uh difference is this money
going to make it's going to make a world
of difference because at the moment
you've got people out there that have
lost everything they've lost their homes
they've lost their their on their way of
living their means of living so it's a
case of this is it's basically do or die
and um what's the response been like
from the local
um we keep getting phone calls we're
inundated with emails of how people can
help what they want to do is fundraisers
or how they can fundraise so we're still
sort of like going to go through it
unfortunately at the moment it's a race
to get Aid out there but this is going
to be a long marathon where this is
going to be sort of the yeah it's going
to be needed over a long period of time
um and on that note you haven't just
started fundraising now you've been
putting efforts in since June right yeah
when the rain started the first fall we
have been working on the ground there
since June originally it was
um just Food Packs but now it's got a
lot more serious than that because
they've got nowhere to cook so now it's
hot meals tents Medical Aid and how much
longer do you think you'll have to keep
going years
in all honesty it's going to be years
because you know when you think this uh
the country the site well the flood area
is the size of the UK
how long is it going to take to clear
that up great thank you very much for
joining us so they've had a successful
bike uh charity event today they've
raised over 30 000 four people in
Pakistan displaced to raise money for
food intense medicine uh over there and
they might be off today but they've got
plenty more planned on the horizon over
the next coming few weeks
I shall Head Live from Peterborough
thanks very much indeed
well the UK's disasters emergency
committee says that they've managed to
raise in just two days
13.5 million pounds and I'm joined now
live by Sally said he's the UK's chief
executive of the disasters emergency
committee uh thanks very much indeed for
speaking to us on this special program
live from Pakistan where are you with
the aid effort right now
so first of all a huge thank you to
everybody that's contributed to the
disasters the most appeal over 30 and a
half million pounds has been raised in
just two days and that's a hard efforts
of people up and down the country is
your reports just show now the scale of
the devastation in Pakistan is
absolutely huge and very very
destructive Bridges destroyed schools
destroyed people's homes and livelihoods
have been washed away but our aiding
organizations 11 organizations who are
working on the ground directly and also
with local Partners including the
Pakistan government and of course the
United Nations to coordinate the scaling
up of urgent emergency aid we are
reaching people with essential supplies
of those who have lost their livelihoods
will be and are getting food those who
have lost their homes are getting uh
shelf emergency shelter tents and the
like and of course distribution of Clean
Water the risk of water-borne diseases
is very very high and it's essential
that people get the aid they need and I
can ensure that your viewers that the
aid organizations on the ground are
coordinating and scaling up for this
huge operation that's absolutely
essential to save and protect lives
I want to talk to you about the future
of the fundraising effort because I have
to say and all the correspondents are
from Sky News here on the ground are
saying that we really need to see more
efforts on the ground it's not just
Financial donations that Pakistan needs
you know I've covered the 2010 floods
and of course we've saw the 2008
devastating earthquake we saw
International Teams flying in to help
people on the ground we're simply not
seeing that and this is a gargantuan
issue here it's a major flood
yeah I think first and foremost we might
give huge credit
um to the local people who are
responding in all emergencies it's the
First Responders communities themselves
helping each other uh rescuing each
other what they have but also it takes
time for the international Aid effort to
get going the coordination is happening
as we speak the logistics of getting
around flying into and dropping Aid into
a country that now has a third of its
area underwater is is very very
difficult but not impossible and Aid is
getting through and will continue to be
scaled up to ensure that we reach as
many people as possible
Sally said from the UK disasters
emergency committee thanks very much
indeed for joining us live here on Sky
News
well here in Pakistan as we've been
speaking I have to tell you that flood
waters are rising certainly right across
the province of sin that this water here
has risen this morning alone and in the
last few hours just before we came on
air there was a tent city on that muddy
Bank behind me over my left shoulder it
has gone people have moved on because
they've heeded the warnings at least
here that they need to leave other
people are refusing and staying in their
homes but as This Disaster unfolds we
are trying to bring you exactly what the
people of Pakistan are going through and
just how much help they really need
thanks very much indeed for joining us
live from Pakistan in this special
program with Stuart Ramsey in the swamp
Valley Cordelia Lynch and Dadu and me
Simon Morrison in seven Sharif
[Music]
thank you